[Musica]
Questo che vedete qui è mio padre ed è
stata la prima persona che mi è venuta
in mente quando ho letto la parola
evoluzione
per due motivi principali
il primo perché è una delle persone più
importanti della mia vita assieme a mia
mamma
e la seconda perché forse inconsciamente
è stato il primo che mi ha fatto entrare
in contatto con cosa voglia dire
evolvere
come
discutendoci spesso e volentieri
evoluzione
Questo è il tema e mentre leggo questa
parola la mia mente comincia a pensare e
cominciò a chiedermi cosa posso dire
Cosa posso raccontare
Dopotutto ogni discorso che viene fatto
qui è un discorso che vale la pena di
ascoltare e riascoltare
E io che cosa ho di speciale da dire a
riguardo
ho continuato a chiedermelo per giorni e
giorni finché Poi ho cominciato a pormi
delle domande diverse ed è stato in quel
momento che riaffiorato uno dei pilastri
del mio vivere una di quelle cose che
forse mi ha sempre fatto evolvere più in
fretta
che
condividere
credo in maniera forte e profonda che
nella condivisione
c'è un qualcosa che pochissime altre
cose può darci se io posso ascoltare la
tua storia e farla mia in qualche modo
avrò in parte vissuto un pezzettino
della tua vita
arricchendo la mia di un qualcosa che
magari non avrei mai potuto vivere
Questo è quello che ho da offrire io
oggi la mia esperienza
sono nata a Treviso nel 1988 E tutto
quello che ho fatto per molti molti anni
e che continua a fare è giocare a
pallacanestro
ogni mio sogno desiderio passione era
rivolto al raggiungimento di tutti
quegli obiettivi che ogni sportivo ha
diventare professionista vincere
campionati giocare in nazionale e in
qualche modo Magari diventare anche
l'idolo dei bambini che seguono questo
sport
nella mia carriera passata tra sveglia
presto yoga la mattina e la respirazione
i bagni nel ghiaccio che vi assicuro
sono devastanti
ho portato la mia atleta a mille gradi
di evoluzione diversi prima era una
ragazzina che scendeva in campo e viveva
di talento ogni cosa che facevo era puro
istinto privo di cognizione come se il
campo fosse il mio parco giochi dove la
razionalità si spegneva completamente e
potevo dare aria alla mia creatività
sportiva
Poi col tempo succede quello che succede
a tutti quanti
entri in ambienti lavorativi diversi e
ti trovi fuori dalla comfort zone a cui
sei abituato e ti ritrovi anche a dover
trovare metodi diversi per poter
sopravvivere nel mio caso con le più
grandi
questo mi ha portato a capire
che in una squadra non puoi fare solo i
conti con il tuo talento devi anche
saper fare i conti con i talenti delle
tue compagne e se vuoi vincere devi
anche riuscire a trovare il modo di
incastrarli e farli funzionare come un
ingranaggio perfetto
così si sviluppa quella maturità che ti
fa capire appunto che in campo non sei
da solo e che spesso i tuoi obiettivi
vengono di gran lunga dopo quelli di
tutto il collettivo magari detto così
può sembrare una cosa scontata in un
contesto di squadra ma lo è davvero
immaginate di avere vent'anni di essere
forti e bravi in quello che fate di
avere aspettative vostre e altrui da
voler rispettare e poi immaginatevi di
essere inseriti in un contesto
lavorativo dove si Ok tu hai i tuoi
sogni però tu sei qui per far
raggiungere i sogni del club Anche se
questo vuol dire alla fine allenamento
portarle borracce e metter via i palloni
mi sono trovata un sacco di volte
in quel periodo a combattere delle lotte
interiori mie alla ricerca sfrenata
della meatleta perché non sapevo più
cos'ero cosa potevo dare quali fossero
le mie capacità in campo Mi guardavo
allo specchio e mi chiedevo dove fosse
finita la Giorgia che entrava in campo e
faceva tutto con quella sfrontatezza e
naturalezza che sembrava essere
scomparsa
ora ripensarci
dico che forse in quel momento ero
troppo giovane per capire che quello che
stavo vivendo in quel preciso istante
Era semplicemente una naturale
evoluzione dell'atleta che ero
Perché a quel punto ero chiamata a
capire che esiste un intero e non solo
io ero chiamata a sapermi modellare
dentro ad un gruppo e non essere
l'uragano che spesso caratterialmente
sono che fa Piazza Pulita attorno a sé
ero chiamata a scoprire altre mie
capacità forse innate poi col senno di
poi posso dirlo che mi hanno portato al
raggiungimento di tutti o quasi i sogni
che avevo quando ero bambina
Se mi guardo indietro e vedo il percorso
che ho fatto come atleta
però quasi un po' mi commuove vedere
dove è stata la vera evoluzione
Scusate ma mi tremano un po' la voce A
ripensarci
[Musica]
vedete quando si atleti e Si è bravi in
quello che si fa
spesso si è esposti a livello mediatico
più di quanto lo sia una qualsiasi altra
persona che fa un qualsiasi altro lavoro
E questo porta chiunque attorno a te a
guardarti con degli occhi strani e ciò
che la gente vede è solo l'atleta
Giorgia la giocatrice di basket Giorgia
che ieri ha giocato male Giorgia la
Capitan della nazionale ti capita mi
capita ancora adesso di ricevere
messaggi su Instagram dove la gente si
rivolge a me come se fossi un qualcosa
di intoccabile distante anni luce dalla
vita di chiunque altro solo per il
semplice fatto che sono un atleta
ciò che da fuori non si vede spesso e
volentieri È che questa etichetta che ti
viene messo addosso finisce per
diventare parte integrante della tua
identità
e finisci per credere che tutto ciò che
sei è un atleta Cioè a livello di
identità tutti identifichi solo e
unicamente come l'atleta
ho subito diversi brutti infortuni nella
mia carriera ma vi posso assicurare che
non c'è niente di paragonabile al
periodo buio in cui non sapevo più che
cos'ero non sapevo più chi ero ad un
certo punto questa etichetta che avevo
addosso mi prudeva e mi prudeva
parecchio Forse perché a quel momento in
quel momento giocare non mi piaceva
nemmeno più così tanto ma se smettevo
chi ero cioè io sono Giorgia la
giocatrice se domani smetto cosa mi
resta ero tormentata dalla voglia di
smettere di giocare ma non potevo perché
per gli altri io quello ero e quindi
quello dovevo fare
sono stati mesi difficili perché alla
fine quando poi ti siedi sul divano
diventa difficile mentire puoi farlo con
gli altri puoi anche farlo con te stessa
per un po' però poi i nodi diventano
talmente tanti che se non cominci pian
piano a sputarli fuori rischi veramente
di soffocarti di bugie e quindi cosa ho
fatto
mi sono resa conto del momento e ho
alzato la mano e ho chiesto aiuto ho
chiesto se c'era qualcuno disposto ad
aiutarmi qualcuno che potesse vedermi
nella mia interezza e non nella mia
singola parte di atleta e quindi mi sono
affidata ad un professionista una
persona appunto che potesse comprendermi
nella totalità
quando ho cominciato
a scoprirmi fuori dal rettangolo di
gioco
È stato lì che ho toccato veramente con
mano Cosa vuol dire evolvere almeno per
me
un'evoluzione che non ha nulla a che
fare con quello che fai nella vita è
un'evoluzione intima l'evoluzione
dell'essere del mio essere che poi non è
stato altro che toccare con mano
l'unicità dell'esistere e prenderne
consapevolezza
che qualsiasi cosa fai nella vita nel
lavoro nell'intimità è fatta a metà se
non sai chi sei e poi il perdersi è solo
una naturale conseguenza del vagare
senza senso
perché la vera sfida è il diventare
persone autentiche ossia collegare
l'essenza con l'azione
e tutto poi attorno a me a te a voi a
chiunque lo abbia la fortuna di
diventarlo ogni cosa prende una luce
completamente diversa
e non è facile perché purtroppo siamo
costantemente circondati da realtà
virtuali e falsità che non corrispondono
neanche minimamente a quello che viviamo
e questo
è ovviamente un problema perché ci fa
perdere per strada l'unica vera
evoluzione che dovrebbe contare sembra
quasi di stare in una giostra che va
avanti e va avanti All'infinito E non ci
dà mai l'opportunità di scendere di
fermarci di respirare di riflettere su
chi siamo
so che finché giocherò E finché farò
questo sport Dovrò continuare a
modificare ad evolvere
a vivere lo sport che faccio in maniera
diversa
Appunto però che faccio non che sono
l'evoluzione finale quella che tutti
dovrebbero toccare con mano è quella di
potersi guardare allo specchio la sera
con la profonda consapevolezza di aver
vissuto secondo la propria identità e i
propri valori perché quello che facciamo
nella vita non può essere
l'identificazione di chi siamo può
essere piuttosto il secchio che
Riempiamo con ogni nostra parte del
nostro essere
non possiamo e non dobbiamo accettare
ogni cosa così com'è se non si
identifica con la nostra luce interiore
perché quella luce che dobbiamo
alimentare perché quella luce che dà un
senso al nostro esistere
mi sarebbe piaciuto 15 anni fa quando
ero più giovane io avere qualche
compagna più esperta che mi dicesse
quanto quello che si è è molto più
importante di quello che si fa o
quantomeno che in quello che si fa ci si
metta tutto quello che sia forse avrei
passato più tempo a conoscermi a capire
chi ero a investigare la mia profondità
invece di investire ogni singola parte
di me per provare a raggiungere dei
riconoscimenti esterni che poi valgono
fino a lì
quando ero più giovane il perdersi era
un fatto eccezionale dedicato a chi
viveva vite un po' diverse come magari
L'ho vissuta io
invece purtroppo adesso
i dati ci dicono che i giovani che si
perdono che vagano nel buio la ricerca
della loro identità purtroppo sono sono
tanti e spesso questi giovani mollano si
fermano soli
come potete vedere qua da marzo 2020 A
marzo 2021 c'è stato un incremento
incredibile
l'idea di suicidio
delle depressioni e delle ansie dei
disturbi alimentari
Allora mi permetto di dire una cosa ai
giovani e la dico con Massimo umiltà
anche a tutte le persone che si sentono
perse
per crescere per evolvere per fare dei
passi avanti spesso è necessario
condividere
sapersi condividere e per condividere
non intendo postare la foto che facciamo
l'aperitivo al mare tutti sorridenti
intendo piuttosto riuscire a mostrarci
nelle nostre più eccezionali fragilità
alle persone giuste
perché è nella condivisione autentica e
nel riuscire a mostrarci senza veli
che esiste la profonda magia della
consapevolezza
quella che ti fa fare l'evoluzione più
importante che ogni essere umano può
fare
quella di guardare alle proprie crepe e
lasciare finalmente passare la luce e
l'amore
concludo con una frase che nei momenti
difficili mi manda sempre avanti e mi
ricorda chi sono non sono ciò che faccio
ma in ogni cosa che faccio ci metto
tutto ciò che sono Grazie per aver
condiviso il vostro tempo con me e
grazie
Anche perché con questa mia condivisione
so di essere nuovamente voluta
[Applauso]
[Musica]